[Music]
foreign
so in the last lecture we introduced
this idea that we might want to be
solving higher order
differential equations ordinary
differential equations which means
differential equations that have higher
derivatives than just a first or a
second derivative so we know from
Newton's Second Law f equals m a it's
easy to get systems that have second
derivatives in a position that's just
acceleration so we've been solving a lot
of systems like this but in the last
lecture I showed you that for example if
you add another spring mass or even
another spring Mass system so that you
have this more complicated physical
system
it's possible to obtain a differential
equation that now in this case has
fourth derivatives instead of just
second derivatives okay so you can write
down the equations for this and you get
two coupled second order Odes for the
first position and the second position
but with some algebra and rearranging
things you can turn that into a single
fourth order ordinary differential
equation
and so today I'm going to show you how
to solve kind of an arbitrarily high
order ordinary differential equation
with nth derivatives n could be five it
could be six it could be 10 million and
what I'm going to show you today totally
still apply so this is kind of a very
general idea of how to solve this
generic ordinary differential equation
and you can write it this way or this
way where we're using the kind of
shorthand notation that a DOT is a
derivative so X double dot is the second
derivative of x with respect to time and
then once this becomes too many
derivatives like the nth derivative I'll
just write X superscript and in
parentheses that's not x to the power n
that's the nth time derivative in this
notation okay
um and we've actually solved these kinds
of ordinary differential equations
before you know for second order systems
by guessing the solution which would be
some exponential function and that's
exactly what we're going to do again
today okay so it's actually like we're
totally ready to solve this we're
equipped to do this let's get started so
we're going to try
a little squeaky apologies we're going
to try X of T equals e to the Lambda T
just like before
and we know that x dot you know x dot
equals Lambda e to the Lambda T we know
that X double dot equals Lambda squared
e to the Lambda T you guessed it x
triple dot
um x triple dot is Lambda cubed e to the
Lambda T and in general the nth
derivative uh the sorry this is too
squeaky even for me uh the nth
derivative of x
D you know the nth derivative of x x
with respect to time is going to be
Lambda to the power n
e to the Lambda T so this is a very nice
pattern that every derivative the nth
derivative has Lambda to the power n out
front of e to the Lambda T so we're
going to try that solution
we're going to plug it in to this
equation these are equivalent equations
and then we're going to derive that
characteristic polynomial that we've
been working with before but now instead
of being a quadratic polynomial now it's
going to be an nth order polynomial
because I'm going to have Lambda to the
power n terms
so let's do that and maybe I'll do green
down here so if I take all of these
expressions for the derivatives and I
plug them into here what I'm going to
get
is uh a n let's say a n
Lambda n
e to the Lambda T that's what I'm going
to have here I'm going to actually every
single term every single term is going
to have an e to the Lambda T we know
this and so I'm going to just pop out my
uh you know e to the Lambda t
times all of this stuff okay every
single term this term and this term and
all of these terms are going to have an
e to the Lambda T so I'm just going to
pop all of those out and just look at
the the other part so a n Lambda to the
N for this term
plus a n minus 1 that coefficient this
is just a number
I'm sorry that's not Lambda subscript n
this is Lambda to the power n
much different okay so this is Lambda to
the power n
Lambda to the power n Plus
a n minus 1 that coefficient times
Lambda to the N minus 1 power plus you
know a n minus 2 Lambda to the N minus 2
plus dot dot dot plus A2
this DDT is going to have a Lambda
squared
plus A1 Lambda plus a naught
all of that
equals zero this is exactly the same
information as my differential equation
just assuming that my solution was e to
the Lambda t
now you might
scan yourself we've always been assuming
that our solution is e to the Lambda T
what if they're what if this is one
solution but there are other Solutions
what if you know hyperbolic cosine
[Music]
Cosh function also solves this that
might be true but one way you could
check that would be to write out the the
Taylor series or power series expansion
for X of T in terms of powers of t
plug that into this equation and you'll
actually come up very quickly with the
realization that yes in fact only
exponential functions and Sines and
cosines work and of course Sines and
cosines are just versions of an
exponential function where Lambda is a
complex number okay we've seen that
before so this is a very reasonable
guess in fact this is kind of the only
base function that can be used to solve
these linear these linear Odes and I
should really be writing that this is
linear these are linear
ode systems okay good so this is
Emil
um essentially just like before and so
essentially what we want to do
is
this has to equal zero so so the only
lambdas that work for this solution are
lambdas that satisfy this expression
equal to zero but this essentially e to
the Lambda t uh uh is basically never
zero this is you know
[Music]
um
this is uh
only zero
when Lambda T goes to negative Infinity
so basically this term can never be zero
and so the only way that this is true is
if this polynomial and Lambda equals
zero okay so that's uh our
characteristic polynomial I'm going to
write it up here again which is you know
a
and Lambda to the N plus a n minus 1
Lambda to the N minus 1 plus dot dot dot
Plus
a two Lambda squared plus A1 Lambda plus
a zero
that has to equal zero and I don't need
my
left bracket here any longer okay I
don't need f equals m a here either
so this is my characteristic polynomial
this is very very important this is the
characteristic polynomial
polynomial
for this differential equation so every
higher order every linear ordinary
differential equation has its own
characteristic polynomial
and it's nice this polynomial is really
easy and we didn't actually have to
compute all these derivatives and plug
them all in you can kind of just read it
off because the coefficients of the nth
power of Lambda in this polynomial is
just the coefficient of the nth
derivative of x in this ordinary
differential equation and that kind of
makes sense based on the structure of
you know all of these derivatives have
powers of Lambda okay so this is the
characteristic polynomial
and this effect from algebra that you uh
will hopefully remember is that this has
this has n
roots
Lambda 1 Lambda 2 dot dot dot to Lambda
n that will satisfy this polynomial
equation now some of those might be
equal there might be repeated Roots but
there will be n lambdas that satisfy
this characteristic polynomial and so in
general
that is going to allow us to write the
general solution X of T in terms of e to
each of these lambdas linear
combinations of each of these lambdas
okay I'm going to write that out because
that's basically it so that's our our
whole uh solution now so what we're
going to say
is that our X of t
is going to be a sum of all of these
base Solutions e to the Lambda T so
there's going to be an e to the Lambda 1
T because whatever you know this first
solution of this characteristic
polynomial that Lambda 1 will definitely
work as a solution so that'll be one and
any coefficient out front is fine I can
multiply that by 5 or 10 or negative 2
or Pi it doesn't matter that's a
solution this is definitely a solution
of this differential equation if Lambda
1 solves this characteristic polynomial
and I can add up all of these Solutions
because this is a linear differential
equation that means that I can if I have
multiple Solutions then the sum of those
Solutions is also a solution okay that's
a really important property I'd like you
to convince yourself you can take you
know a couple of these e to the Lambda
one t and e to the Lambda 2T add them up
and convince yourself that those also
still satisfy this differential equation
very important so if I have this I also
have plus C2 e to the Lambda 2 t plus
dot dot dot plus you know all the way up
to c n e to the Lambda n t
this is my generic
solution
of a higher order ordinary differential
equation system so this is actually
pretty simple any high order ordinary
differential equation you can write down
in terms of you know nth derivatives of
some State X you can write down its
characteristic polynomial solve for the
roots of that polynomial you can do that
numerically you can do that using I'll
show you in the next lecture you can do
that using eigenvalues you can rewrite
this as a system of n first order
equations which will be a matrix system
and the eigenvalues of that Matrix will
be this character the roots of this
characteristic polynomial but however
you do it you find these lambdas and now
you have your generic solution is a
linear combination just some combination
of all of those e to the Lambda T's
because this is a solution this is a
solution they're all individually
Solutions and so when I add them up
because it's linear this will also be a
solution and I can scale you know I can
I can multiply each of these by any
coefficient I like and it's still a
solution
good now if I wanted to determine what
were the actual coefficients for a
particular solution for a given actual
set of initial conditions I would have
to use those initial conditions you know
uh to actually satisfy these these
coefficients so essentially what you
would do is
um
what you would do is you would need
kind of n initial conditions and initial
conditions
uh to uniquely determine these constants
to uniquely
determine
these constants
that I'm just going to put in Brackets
and call C you know k
from k equals 1 to n okay I got n
constants in that set right there and
typically you would use x you would use
like X at time 0 and x dot at time 0 and
x double dot at time 0 all the way to
the nth derivative of x at sorry the N
minus one derivative of x
uh at Time Zero the N minus 1 derivative
here
X
n minus one derivative at time zero and
this set of this is these are kind of
initial conditions so if x was a
position this would be the initial
position the initial velocity the
initial acceleration and so on and so
forth
you would use this
to solve
for uh you know my Vector of C1 C2
C3 dot dot dot down to C
cm
okay now some of you might remember you
know you could actually it's kind of fun
this this would this would be another um
I don't think I'm going to do a video
lecture on this because it'll be a
little bit boring um but this would be a
cool exercise for you to do it'll take
20 minutes
would be to actually you know take this
generic solution and then write down
this and then x dot X double dot x
triple dot all the way to X N minus one
the N minus 1 derivative so that's n
equations
plug in 0 to all of them so all of the
exponentials are going to go away so the
first equation is going to be C1 C2 C3
dot dot dot the next equation is going
to be C1 lambda1 C2 Lambda 2 c 2 3
Lambda 3 and so on the third equation is
going to be C1 Lambda 1 squared C2
Lambda 2 squared and so on
and that is going to give you a system
of equations
for how X these X naughts these initial
conditions depend on these coefficients
and if you solve that system of
equations you can solve for these
constants in terms of this initial data
and that big Matrix you're going to
solve for that's called the ronskian if
I don't if memory serves me okay so
that'll be pretty pretty useful
okay maybe I'll actually do that in the
last two minutes I might now I've got a
hankering for uh for some good old Ron
skins uh but before I do that because
that's going to be a little uh a little
hairy
just a recap we can now solve any higher
order ordinary differential equation
that's a big deal okay so like any
mechanical system that coupled system
with lots and lots of degrees of freedom
I have like you know not just one
pendulum swinging but I have another
pendulum below it swinging at least for
small angles I can write that as a
fourth order ordinary differential
equation system and I can solve it by
assuming my solution is e to the Lambda
T taking all of those derivatives and
plugging in to get my characteristic
polynomial solving for the roots of that
characteristic polynomial and building
up my generic solution in terms of
linear combinations of those terms and
then I can get the coefficients by
solving for them based on my initial
data in the next lecture what I'm going
to show you this is a very important
sequence so this lecture and the next
few lectures are pretty important
I'm going to show you how to rewrite
this nth order ordinary differential
equation in a single variable
into a system of n first order ordinary
differential equations only a single
derivative in all of those terms but now
that's going to be a coupled system of n
first order equations and that's going
to be a matrix system of equations and
the eigenvalues of that Matrix are going
to be the roots of this characteristic
polynomial that's huge that's how we're
going to motivate eigenvalues and
eigenvectors and that's how actually you
know in reality we're going to solve you
know find these roots and solve these
equations is by writing these as big
systems of first order equations and
then doing Matrix linear algebra which
we're really good at and more
importantly our computers are really
good at okay
that's coming up uh if you have patience
let's do a Ron scan okay
um this is kind of fun I think it's fun
so I'm going to erase this and then
we're going to do that
okay I'm a little nervous what I just
got myself into uh because I will be
perfectly honest I have not written down
a ronskian or inverted oronskian or done
any ronsky and algebra for goodness
gracious probably 20 years okay and I
haven't done this for my class I'm it's
it's probably easy let's hope so
so what we're going to do is I'm going
to just try to give you a sketch of how
you solve for these coefficients given
your initial data for this generic
solution
and I vaguely remember how to do this
but I think again I want you to see how
we reason on our feet with first
principles
um and just kind of basic logic Okay so
we know that we have X at times 0 x dot
at Time Zero X double dot at time zero
so we're going to use that and the way
we're going to use that is we're
literally going to compute this and all
of its derivatives and plug in zero okay
and we're going to try to get a big
Matrix system of equations and from this
data representing this data and this
data relating these two vectors of data
okay this is information I have and this
is information I want good
um
and so I think what I'm going to do is
I'm just going to write down you know
okay this system here I also have
um you know x dot equals C1 Lambda 1 e
to the Lambda 1 t plus C2 Lambda 2 e to
the
Lambda 2T plus dot dot Plus
C and Lambda n e to the Lambda n t
that's fine and I'm just going to take a
leap of faith here and write down that
you know I if the second derivative I'm
going to get another power of Lambda 1
and Lambda 2 and Lambda n the third
derivative I'm going to get another
power and so the kind of you know
whatever nth derivative is just going to
be C1
Lambda 1 to the n
e to the Lambda 1T plus C2 Lambda 2 to
the power n e to the Lambda 2T plus dot
dot dot plus c n Lambda n to the power n
e to the Lambda n t no big deal this is
just
pretty straightforward and importantly
if I plug in time 0 because all of this
is initial data initial just means that
time zero X naught x dot naught X double
dot naught literally means I plug in you
know I evaluate these derivatives at
time zero and all of these exponentials
become one e to the zero is one so this
is really really nice so now I'm going
to write this out and I'm going to write
this out as you know X where do I want
to live X
zero
equals
just
C1 plus C2 plus C3 plus C4 plus dot dot
dot
um
C1 plus C2 plus C3 plus dot dot dot plus
C and
x dot not again I'm going to evaluate
this at time zero and that's going to be
C1 Lambda 1 plus C2 Lambda 2 plus C3
Lambda 3 plus dot dot dot plus c n
land and I'll write down my second
derivative and then I'm gonna
stop X double dot naught this is going
to be C2 Lambda 1 ah not C2 C1
okay this is going to be C1 Lambda 1
squared plus C2 Lambda
2 squared plus c 3 Lambda 3 squared plus
dot dot dot plus c n Lambda N squared
dot dot dot X the N minus oneth
derivative evaluated at 0 is going to be
C1 Lambda 1 to the N minus 1.
plus C2 Lambda 2 to the N minus 1 plus
C3 Lambda 3 to the N minus 1 plus dot
dot dot dot plus c n
Lambda n to the N minus 1. okay that's
this is it seems harder than it is all I
did was I took all the derivatives and I
plugged in time equals zero and all the
e to the lambdas went away and I just
get this really simple sum of
coefficients and lambdas and now here's
where it gets interesting this is where
and I hope this is called the Ron scan
it's been again 20 years I think it's
called the ronskian I can write this as
a matrix system of equations now
I can say that this is a vector X naught
x dot naught X double dot at Time Zero
all the way down to X N minus 1 at time
zero this is a big Vector of data
and this is going to be a matrix
times
my coefficient Vector uh C1
C2
C3 dot dot dot
CN and look how easy it is to write this
this Matrix down okay so the first row
is X naught equals some numbers times
this Vector well all of those
coefficients are one it's C1 plus C2
plus C3 plus C4 so it's literally a row
of one one one dot dot dot dot one
if I take this times this I get my first
equation
my second row is also simple the
coefficients are just Lambda 1 Lambda 2
Lambda 3. so I can write down
Lambda 1 Lambda 2 Lambda 3 dot dot dot
Lambda n multiply that okay this is
um also now my second equation those are
the coefficients of these constants in
the second equation my third equation is
just Lambda 1 squared
Lambda 2 squared Lambda 3 squared dot
dot dot Lambda N squared and my n minus
1 equation this is kind of fun I like
doing these kinds of things this would
be Lambda 1
to the power n minus 1.
trying to speak and write is dangerous
this is Lambda
uh one
to the N minus 1 Lambda 2 to the N minus
1 Lambda 3 to the N minus one dot dot
dot Lambda n to the N minus one and now
because I have this data
and I know what my lambdas are I can
build this Matrix and I literally just
invert this Matrix times this Vector to
solve for C let's call this I'm starting
to think this might not be called the
ronskian actually it's not the Ron scan
the Ron scheme is a matrix of
derivatives
um
but it's very closely related okay it's
very closely related and that's actually
uh go do some homework on Wikipedia I'm
going to do the same thing this is not
exactly the Ron scheme I'm pretty sure
um
uh this has a name
um
I'm blanking on the name but this this
iterative uh
power Matrix oh it'll come to me but
let's just call this a big Matrix
m
and let's call this a big Matrix of
initial conditions called you know this
Vector of initial conditions we'll just
call this like
uh D because that's my data and we'll
call this C my coefficients we can solve
for C we just say C equals the inverse
of this m Matrix
times D and so that's how you solve for
those coefficients in general uh for
this this differential equation
um what is this called an arnaldi
sequence a krylov Subspace uh when you
have these these Powers this comes up
into the dynamic mode decomposition all
the time and I'm just blanking on it
some of you are probably screaming into
your TV sets anyway
um easy to do that's my my point here is
that you know you have the basic skills
and knowledge to solve for these things
from first principles right just use the
information you have if I have a bunch
of data evaluated at Time Zero you know
and it's x dot and X double dot compute
x dot and X double dot plug in zero and
see if you get something that you can
solve for okay thank you
thank you
[Music]